it's december 2nd 2021 and so it's time
for another monthly update video
obviously this will be the last one
for the year 2021 but i might do another
end of the year video as well we'll see
how that goes i always like to begin by
talking about three big things that i'd
like to bring to your attention so big
thing number one if everything goes as
it should
we
should see
stoicism today
volume 3 going out to the press
self-published on amazon this is a book
of really great articles from the
stoicism today blog edited by myself and
my co-editor leah goldrick and all the
proceeds go to the modern stoicism
organization so that's one big thing
big thing number two we're going to be
starting another year of worlds of
speculative fiction and so as always i'm
going to give
all of you the opportunity
to be involved and to
suggest and vote on some of the entries
that i'll be doing this coming year big
thing number three something that we
didn't get to by the end of november but
we will definitely have coming out in
the weeks ahead
merch merch for
the channel merch for a bunch of kind of
silly things merch for the half hour
hegel project ways in which you can show
that you uh
like and would be interested in in in
some way promoting publicly
your connection to the stuff that i talk
about and teach about so those are the
three big things let's talk now about
november november was a pretty busy and
even in some respects brutal month i had
all of my classes ongoing
and lots and lots of grading to do and
wrapping things up getting ready for the
big push that happens now in this month
of december that always takes some
planning in november i also
held quite a few online events you know
my usual
hegel q a and discussion forums both the
public and the patreon exclusive
i did some live readings
i held a political theory and practice
discussion about aristotle
did an ama as usual and we had our metal
class
for the month which went really really
well and the video for that you can find
if you
look at the video description for this
one
i also got my classes totally lined up
for the coming semester meaning lined up
in the sense of i know what i'm teaching
not in the sense that the class shells
have been entirely built out that's
going to happen
partly this month and partly next month
for milwaukee institute of art and
design i am teaching existentialist
philosophy and literature and world
religions and for carthage college i am
teaching medieval philosophy so those
are going to be a lot of fun and those
will involve down the line shooting some
additional videos i mentioned the
stoicism today volume 3 book
that has been an awful lot of work not
just editing but doing all the things
that are required to get it into amazon
self-publishing fortunately my co-editor
shouldered the heaviest of the burdens
on that but even you know with that
there's a lot going on as well as
editing the stoicism today
blog along with my um my assistant
editor harold covley
so that's you know kept me going quite a
bit there's been some stuff that you
know had to be sorted out after stoicon
and after stoic week there's always some
follow-up stuff so that's been a lot
video production
i was hoping to get six half hour hegel
videos done this last month i actually
got only half of that but we did get
into a new
section the very final
part of the religion portion of the work
so that's pretty cool
i got two book review videos done
one that i gave a qualified endorsement
to one that i gave a full endorsement to
links to those can be found below as
well and
my my wife andy and i went on to
a podcast and also did a video about
stoicism and marriage with massimo
pigliucci and robert coulter had a great
conversation about that
wisdom for life you know we had the
radio show i also released a video
um and there was also an evil saddler
video that you might have noticed
popping up people seem to be into that
so i can't promise when and where he'll
show up again but i'm sure that we'll
see
more of that bastard um
and then what else i shot some i shot a
lot of uh footage for my
leguin earth c class um fantasy and
philosophy ursula k le guin's earthsea
it released a lot of videos on the
farthest shore and some on to hanu their
fourth novel
we are now finishing up the class so you
can guess my students have a lot of
videos that you haven't seen yet but
i'll be releasing them over time first
early releasing them to my patreon
supporters and then to the
general public
podcast work the saddlers lectures
podcast i finished releasing the podcast
episodes on miguel de una muno's tragic
sense of life then went into the ever
popular judith jarvis thompson the
trolley problem right
and then after that i i edited and
released some on freud's introductory
lecture 31 which is probably one of the
best places to start if you want to
understand freud's notion of the
personality and the unconscious and then
finally i've been releasing and editing
um podcast episodes on aristotle nick
mccann ethics books eight and nine not
super happy with the sound quality but
those were recorded before i started
using my
sound recorder with a lapel mic so the
sound is as good as it gets
after tweaking it and stuff like that i
also went on the radio a number of times
you know we have the wisdom for life
radio show that my
friend and co-host dan hayes and i
produce but i've been also going on to
riverwest radio as a
co-host for a different kind of show
their drive time with river west show
which is you know more topical
current events
riffing off of each other's stuff and
then interviewing some some guests and
so that's that's been a lot of fun
as well so that's
november
for the month of december the calendar
is particularly packed in the first two
weeks because i'm taking
for the most part the last two weeks as
just some down time for myself where
i'm going to be doing some some writing
getting my classes ready
taking it easy you know getting to the
gym a bit more regularly all those sorts
of things and enjoying myself at
christmas and new year's
getting together with with some friends
perhaps and some family we'll see how
that works but here's what the calendar
holds on saturday the 4th at 12 o'clock
that's that's central time remember all
times are in central time because they
are online events i will be having the
ama that's ask me anything for december
so you can show up and get your
questions in
you might actually want to look at some
of the older amas if you've got a
anchoring to ask questions about like
jordan peterson or g-jack you know
things i've answered many many times
already
after that same day the fourth at 2 p.m
for patreon supporters i will be having
my philosophy chat session and since
it's christmas i'm going to open it up
usually it's only at a certain level in
patreon but i'm going to open it up to
all of the patreon supporters
on the ninth that's a thursday at noon i
will be doing a live reading from my
book a reason fulfilled by revelation
the 1930s christian philosophy debates
in france we're now finally getting into
maurice blondell
on the 11th at noon i'll be having my
political theory and practice discussion
you'll see the link to that below but
you can also find it in the channel
because it's a it's a live streaming
event
just like the ama is
on the
15th this is a very packed week
which is a wednesday at 5 p.m we'll have
our hegel
q a and discussion session that is for
the general public so anybody's invited
anybody can come in that's video
conferencing and talking about hegel and
german idealism with me
on the 16th at noon we'll have another
live reading from reason fulfilled by
revelation probably get through the rest
of the blondel stuff
on the 18th we will have our classic
metal class me and scott truly we are
going to be discussing
metal identity as understood through
songs so songs that are specifically
referencing metal and how that
contributes to metals self-understanding
through its musicians and it's fan base
that is at noon it's a lot of fun
you can join in scott and i are talking
but we answer questions and comments
that people leave in the chat
on the 19th which is a sunday so this is
a little bit unusual we're going to be
having our worlds of speculative fiction
and we're going to be talking about this
massive tome neil stephenson's anathem
people have been requesting this for
years i have been slowly reading my way
through it and we'll we'll talk about
this beginning at noon i'll have a video
premiere which you can join in on and
engage in live chat and then at 1 30 or
you know around that time we'll have a
more intimate zoom session for
discussing the work
then we jump all the way ahead to the
end of the month on the 30th at 6 00 pm
we'll have our
monthly mke that is milwaukee's stoic
fellowship meeting
and we'll be talking about what we'll do
in the coming year and the last thing
that i do have to say about events is
that remember i'm on
drive time with river west at 4 pm
central
on the 8th which is a wednesday and on
the 22nd also a wednesday and we have
the wisdom for life radio show
at
every saturday 5 p.m you can tune in to
either of these shows anywhere in the
world just by going to riverwest radio
and clicking listen live so you don't
have to be in the milwaukee area to hear
them
video work i'm going to be
cranking away at the half hour hegel um
we're now in a new section which is
quite good i'll be doing some more book
reviews i i owe quite a few of those um
and i'll be releasing more of the ursula
k le guin certainly those on tahanu i
might hold off on the last two books
until the new year releasing those
i'll probably do some personal videos
you know the sadler stories i might do
some other things some advice videos
we'll see what goes on evil sadler might
show up especially since there's a
holidays uh period coming up and you
know that seems to bring him out
and i might do some other things i'm not
quite sure exactly what i will be doing
some core concept videos though i've had
some foucault thumbnails sitting on my
desktop waiting to have videos shot on
them for quite a while so i want to get
to those
and i'm looking at shooting some content
for my existentialism class coming up on
sir and kierkegaard's the sickness on to
death a work that i have not shot video
on previously and people have been
asking about and we'll see if i do
anything more after that that's already
quite a bit
i will be doing more
work with the podcast
there's a lot of stuff a lot of content
to crank out
with the aristotle's
nick mccain ethics books eight and nine
lots and lots of stuff about friendship
and relationships that i think would be
useful to keep on uh generating the
content on and then i'll probably start
doing some more sadler's shorts because
those can be quite nice as well and i've
been considering doing some stuff for
riverwest radio
that would be little snippets about
critical thinking and fallacies and how
not to be taken in so if i get to those
we'll we'll see you know
maybe i will maybe i won't i'll probably
also have some content specifically
about stoicism today
volume 3
which we're hoping to have out so people
can start purchasing it as christmas
gifts
and um
you know i'll probably have a video
about the worlds of speculative fiction
and what's coming for the next year
i might do something about uh the merch
that we're going to have coming out so
stay tuned for all of those things
i hope that everybody has a
decent month as we round out 2021 which
has been quite a year uh much like it's
its predecessor 2020
and that's that's pretty much all that
i've got on my end
you